rory old pal how are you i am
so good i am doing so great
really mentally affected or physically
affected by the current state of the
world
i am terrific i've been doing a lot of
zoom interviews
with a lot of people uh your setting
looks the shittiest
i'm going to say that right now and
that's what i was going for there's a
lot of people out there
there's look here's who you've had as
guests conan
liars they want to decorate back here
they're going to go things are great
they
they're live it's like instagram what
people are doing on instagram
not me not me i didn't even put that
there for anyone who can read it
you can barely read it i love that even
your sign promoting your new show robbie
on comedy central is um impossible to
read
i didn't put that there i would never
take credit for that
all right well listen we've got a lot to
talk about you rascal you
uh i was thinking about your life you're
a road comic you're constantly
on the go you're you're always away from
your daughter it must be so nice for you
to be spending time with her
it is um i my wife probably
wishes i could get back out on the road
uh right about now
but yeah with my daughter we're playing
games
non-stop and uh yeah we're
you know when you're gone you you go on
the road you come back
that's what the relationship is to
actually be home is a whole new
is a whole new type of relationship and
it's great
it's the best kid oh there she is hi hi
elliot
did you see conan say hi conan hi you
look pretty elliot
thanks this is mine who told you you
could borrow that
throw that from you that's terrible
[Music]
hide and go seek i am talking to conan
but i i why don't you hide and then i
will come and
get you uh are you really gonna
find me or are you just gonna take
me into a tickle fest well i'll do both
if i find you
you are getting tickled yeah you better
get out of here get your jet
so she's gonna go oh i didn't want
america to see that i talked to her like
that
uh is she gonna uh she's gonna hide now
and then
you're gonna go hide and go seek is one
of the best games these kids
they don't know how long it takes to be
found
and if they commit to the hiding place
it's a good
hour two hours of just catching up on
some golf
you know what i mean well i don't think
that's a so wait you just are going to
let her
hide somewhere in the house for up to
two three hours
yeah adrenaline is pumping the whole
time my adrenaline's pumping cause i'm
getting some stuff done
i'm watching tv and you know
okay yeah that sounds uh and and
one time she came out she was hiding and
she came out and i was having ice cream
and that was very traumatizing for her
not for you never her the best for me
all right well i uh i i you should
go and why are you drinking out of a jar
vodka in a jar
starting a new company it's called vodka
in a jar
nothing says issues like vodka
i think you're gonna make a lot of money